pour démarrer une sordide affaire devant
le tribunal judiciaire de Blois celle de
ce bébé abandonné et retrouvé positif à
la cocaïne affaire que nous vous avions
compté ici même il y a un mois des
analyses ultérieures avaient révélé que
l'enfant de 2 ans avait ingéré de la
drogue sans doute par accident le procès
se tient en ce moment même mais sans la
mère qui ne s'est pas présenté à la
barre les explications sur place
d'Hélène chapelet Jennifer comparaissait
libre pourtant elle ne s'est pas
présenté cet après-midi devant le
tribunal correctionnel de Blois elle
devait comparaître pour soustraction à
ses obligations légales compromettant la
santé la sécurité la moralité ou
l'éducation de son enfant nous n'aurons
donc pas d'explication sur ce qu'il l' a
poussé le 5 septembre dernier a laissé
son enfant sans surveillance dans un
appartement qui n'était pas le sien pas
d'explication non plus sur le fait que
son fils était alors positif à la
cocaïne le mineur vit désormais dans une
famille d'accueil un juge des enfants a
décidé de de son placement jusqu'en
septembre
2024 ces intérêts sont désormais
représentés par l'UDAF 41 l'idée c'était
aussi de pouvoir se confronter aux
explications de la maman qui
malheureusement est pas présente
aujourd'hui à cette audience donc ça
laissera forcément un petit goût de
d'amertume euh et l'idée c'était de de
représenter et de faire valoir ses
droits euh dans le cadre d'une
constition partie civile euh on
sollicitait enfin en toutous les cas je
vais solliciter 1500 € de intérêt en
réparation du préjudice moral la
prévenue d'origine nigériane serait en
attente d'une régularisation quant au
père de l'enfant il vivrait près de
liyon mais n'aurait pas demandé sa garde
le petit Mohamed est né à Blois il
n'aurait pas subi de coup ni de mauvais
traitement lors de son hospitalisation
il n'a pas manifesté de manque preuve
peut-être qu'il s'agissait d'un incident
isolé